what's going on guys this is rob and we
are here with strange academy now i want
to test this out because i have no idea
whether or not you guys would be
receptive to it something else i also
want to point out here i'm in the
process of going back through and and
kind of getting back into reorganizing
the old x-men comics those guys who
don't know when jonathan hickman's whole
house and powers of x picked up we
basically paused our coverage of like
the mid-2000s x-men comics which
honestly i think is probably one of the
greatest eras in x-men history and then
we started covering hickman stuff and so
once that's done we're going to go back
to that so things that lead into like
messiah complex messiah war all that
kind of stuff we're going to go back and
cover all that good stuff so uh yeah
just be aware of that i'm debating on if
i want to dedicate a day to it or do it
it's like every day over the course of
the week is like a background series
which we've experimented with before and
you guys really seem to like it but
nonetheless so here's the thing about
strange academy so strange academy is a
really really cool idea right it's a
really really cool concept and honestly
this story is some of the most fun that
i've ever had reading a doctor strange
comic
i don't know what it is but like reading
stories where like teenagers gain powers
it's just fun because it takes me back
to when i was younger and i wish like i
had powers and i was like a little kid
and a teenager it's just fun stuff uh so
what this does here is this initially
picks up with a young girl by the name
of emily bright and basically she's
writing a letter to doctor strange which
is cute right she calls a mr strange
right but it's pretty cute but basically
it's designed to kind of give us this
sort of synopsis on what's going on that
at a relatively young age she discovered
that she was able to do things that were
basically magical in nature uh there
really isn't a whole lot of explanation
as to how this happened it's simply just
that she was right one day she was able
to levitate her dog while she was
hanging out with her friends eventually
she showed her mom really showed both of
her parents that kind of a thing they
didn't necessarily know how to uh how to
explain it but the thing about this and
what's really intriguing here is that as
most of you guys know when it comes to
magical energy magic can be used for a
variety of facts right it's not one of
these things we're talking about like
emily developed telepathy right where
she just developed like the ability to
read minds you can do a lot with the
ability to read minds but having the
ability to basically manipulate magical
energy is really no different than
having the ability to manipulate ambient
energy and if you can manipulate ambient
energy you can do virtually anything
it's just a matter of how much control
you have over your powers and so as a
result of this there comes a point when
emily's walking her dog and of course
her dog is hit by a car and the results
of this is she actually describes it in
saying like like maybe you'll believe me
maybe you won't i don't really know but
i felt death right i actually felt it
coming without knowing what i was doing
i pushed it away she in effect healed
her dog now there's a couple different
ways to interpret this and this is
really what you get into when you start
talking about the ability to manipulate
ambient energy inside of any one
particular universe either the statement
i push death away is metaphorical in the
sense of i healed my dog and therefore
my dog didn't die or she actually did it
right that like death as we know comes
in the form of mistress death right the
one true form of death and that
everybody else out there is essentially
like a facsimile right like kind of a an
avatar of mistress death so like hella
and like all those different people who
were there again it's not necessarily
guaranteed it's really more just kind of
a guess on behalf of fans but the thing
is it's entirely possible that when
mistress death was coming for this dog
the shoe was pushed away right now most
likely it's metaphorical and it's just
the way in which it was phrased but it's
just one of those things where coming to
this realization that she was able to do
something like that she basically starts
kind of experimenting with her magic
more and more and this ultimately leads
to her of course being under a tree
while she's doing this and then the tree
attacking her right which is kind of
bonkers now of course you end up getting
zelma who basically shows up out of
nowhere and essentially rescues her and
then takes her home to her parents to
kind of explain what's going on now for
those of you guys who don't know who
zelma is zelma is kind of like a modern
day clia but not really so clea back in
the day was basically well at least at
one point in the early days was the
protege of stephen strange then
eventually his girlfriend and then
eventually his wife and then eventually
the ruler of the dark dementia
right like like damn what happened to
you and your wife well uh she ended up
taking over the dark dimension and uh
we've kind of been enemies ever since
you know it goes that way sometimes
right it's the season of breakups
but it's just one of those things so uh
so so the the role that zelma plays is
kind of like a modern day sort of
assistant slash protege of stephen
strange there doesn't really seem to be
any romantic chemistry there between the
two uh it really seems to be more of
like teacher and and mentor right that
really seems to be what it is and she's
kind of like the assistant to a degree
right but she is still exceedingly
capable now when she gets back here
what's really cool about this is she
basically explains to the parents of
emily that emily needs to go to a
magical school right emily's got to go
to hogwarts so like she has to go to a
magical school
where she basically learns or at least
where she will learn how to use her
powers now this is obviously a modern
day depiction or at least a magical
depiction of like the xavier school for
gifted youngsters the funny thing about
this is that it's a relatively new
concept in marvel comics honestly the
idea of like a particular place where
young people learn how to use their
powers that's been around for a long
time the xavier institute really being
the more popular one but there's also
like the future foundation of reed
richards there's avengers academy
there's all kinds of stuff right there's
all kinds of things out there one of the
things that ends up happening is of
course the parents are initially against
it which it makes sense right like
somebody shows up on your doorstep says
hey uh so your daughter is basically a
witch and we're gonna have to whisk her
off to a magical school that you can't
visit just trust us everything will be
okay right i mean that sounds like a
recipe for just disaster
[Laughter]
for any number of shady situations but
ultimately it ends up being emily that
kind of talks your parents into it to a
degree and so of course she ends up
traveling to this school and what's
really cool about this it really does
kind of give off these hogwarts vibes
right where like she literally ends up
traveling with zelma and then they
basically go through like this door
which is really just kind of uh kind of
traveling through a pocket dimension
only to find another secret door and
then once they enter that secret door
they end up on bourbon street in new
orleans not only you guys have been to
new orleans man that place is legit
bourbon street doesn't really look like
that right it means just a ton of people
walking around it's like the it's like
it's like uh it's like times square
right in new york except in louisiana
but of course they end up passing
through what isn't affect this kind of
secret gate uh that nobody really seems
to notice or pay any attention to and
that leads to what is in effect the
strange academy so again very much
hogwarts vice those guys who don't
really aren't really familiar with like
the harry potter mythos there were
spells that were cast on places like
hogwarts so people wouldn't actually see
it for what it was if they got too close
they would remember they had to do
something else and they would leave
there are all kinds of enchantments
there to basically make sure the general
public didn't just wonder into the
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry which would have kind of been
hilarious
if that had happened but it's one of
those things where what you also get is
a kind of containment spell right where
basically you can have what is in effect
an infinitely expanding space inside of
a finite space right defies all laws of
physics but as soon as emily gets there
she's immediately met by this girl named
shaylee right who's just ridiculously
just happy right and just ridiculously
excited and it's one of those hilarious
things because she just she just she's
like bubbly and fun
and it's really interesting to see but
you end up basically finding out that
emily is really more of like the newest
recruit here right there's like other
people who are basically around this
area what's really funny is you actually
get these two guys one of which is named
eric and the other one is alvi and
they're actually from asgard right like
they're actually from the realm of
asgard and that's really what's gonna
happen here is that over the course of
this you end up having somebody who
comes through of course one of the
magical portals and as soon as these
asgardian kids like see this person they
see a frost giant and immediately start
attacking of course loki's observing all
of this just like man this is this is
kind of interesting right watching
everything pop off and it's kind of like
no no no this person they're basically
here as like a student and that's when
you basically get like doyle dormammu
right the son of dormammu now here's the
thing as most of you guys know dormammu
is opie but he's ridiculously powerful
and so when it turns out that dormammu
has a son things get pretty wild now
here's the thing in this comic we're not
gonna find out where his son came from
uh it's simply that dormammu actually
has a son and it's wild because the
asgardians immediately attack him and he
was like okay so like i mean that's a
little judgy but like one of the things
to notice here and this is what's so
intriguing is that while it is kind of a
joke situation right in the sense that
it's like hey guys look i'm cool you
know it's cool everything's awesome
right these people are launching
everything they have at doyle dormammu
and it's not doing any good because he's
just kind of dodging their attacks for
the greatest of ease they pose no real
challenge to him at all and i think the
big thing here is that's designed to
really show just how powerful dormammu
is right like in the end when it comes
to people like asgardians using magic
and powers and things like that they're
for the most part paltry against
somebody like dormam right like the
wrong could just show up in asgard and
just lay waste to everything and that
would basically be the end of that right
but this entire conflict is basically
stopped by jericho drum right by brother
voodoo and so that's kind of the funny
thing is he basically tells them like
look doyle dormammu is essentially a
student here right like he is a fellow
student here as much as any of you guys
and so loki who's really observing this
is like okay so like the lord of the
dark dimension has a son and he's a
student here great idea no way this goes
badly
so it's really it's really hilarious
right it's just one of those little
those little funny things but ultimately
they're all basically brought inside of
the uh of the mansion and that's one of
the things right loki is here jericho
drum is here and you're going to see a
lot of familiar faces who are basically
going to be instructors here um or at
least guest instructors during their
during their their training at the
strange academy but the other cool thing
is they're given a kind of tour of this
whole place right and so one of the
things that's kind of told here is that
the building itself was built in the
1800s and like you all noticed when you
were outside the gates nothing here has
ever been what it seems for example your
classroom for the magic of the cosmos is
not what you would expect when they open
the door it's quite literally the cosmos
right like literally just space
right you know she says like we have
actual classrooms here this is the
mystic parasites lab if you find
yourself with an extra arm you'll learn
what critter in what dimension would
have the right spectral bacteria to heal
it right beyond the classrooms you all
have access to my library and all of its
content we just ask that you take care
of the books as some of them basically
predate time itself now one of the funny
things one of the comments that these
kids make is like that doesn't make any
sense like how can it possibly pre-date
time here's an important thing to
understand here right this is this is an
important thing to grasp whenever it
comes to like the magical concepts of
the marvel universe existence at least
as far as zelma really explains it that
they predate time itself there are
beings out there that existed before
anything ever existed right like before
anything ever ever occupied anything
right so for example the being oblivion
right oblivion represents the space
between multiversal collapses right so
when a multiverse collapses when it's
destroyed by whatever manner or whatever
means so if we use the sixth iteration
of the multiverse that multiverse
collapsed because the dweller in
darkness cracked the m cron crystal and
it sucked in all existence inside of it
and then exploded outward in a big bang
with a new multiverse if we take the
seventh iteration of the multiverse
which was destroyed during the events of
jonathan hickman's secret wars right
like regardless of whatever whatever
concept it happens to be oblivion
represents the spaces in between the
absence of all existence you can
extrapolate that out and say oblivion
basically represents the concept of
nothing that existed before the
formation of the first universe right
the first firmament again it's all very
abstract and very meta-textual but there
are beings out there that predate all of
creation and by whatever manner and
whatever means and for whatever reason
some of them just wrote down information
now some of these scrolls that zelma is
talking about the predate time she's
using that in the context of like it
predates our universe right so there are
beings like the dweller in darkness who
existed before the current universe that
basically transcribed the the powers
they had in their possession right how
to use those abilities and things along
those lines and those were passed into
the the new universe when it was created
and the new multiverse as well so again
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because what you're seeing here are
basically beings right these young
teenagers representing different aspects
of the world as we know it some of these
teenagers are from asgard some of these
teenagers are from the swamp of the man
thing right some of these teenagers are
just like some kid from the suburbs in
some town some are frost giants all
these are individuals who in some form
or fashion are all basically tied to the
idea or concept of ambient magical
energy and so that's when basically the
students are paired off into their
roommates right now uh the funny like
this is like the funniest moment right
where like shaylee is talking to emily
and she's like yeah we're roomies i
can't wait i hope you like staying up
late and talking and popcorn and in the
morning i'm making waffles
it's basically that right like it's just
like she like looks like the most fun
person ever to be around but the thing
about this is like some of them are
basically paired up intentionally right
like they don't like each other right
it's just one of those things where it's
kind of like dormammu and like one of
the asgardian twins or as guardian
brothers are basically paired up right
that kind of a thing and it's it's
really really interesting because some
of them actually actually end up asking
to basically be traded out right to get
different rooms and it's like no no you
need to learn to work with your enemies
with people that you don't like you have
to learn to work with them now the funny
thing about this and as you can probably
imagine as time goes on a kind of
respect will actually form among all
these different students right they'll
find themselves unified in different
ways now while they're all basically
eating dinner and they're all kind of
just talking amongst themselves in terms
of like why they're here and and what
what brought them all here like what
their their commonalities are like you
guys know how that is i mean any of you
guys who've ever been young people right
like when a bunch of you are grouped
together you try to find some kind of
common denominator among you and will we
tie the poor soul that has nothing in
common with any of you right because
then they're the outliers like well we
all like this show what about you such
and such well i'm not a big fan of it
you stay over there
it's that kind of a thing right it's a
rite of passage right it's just one of
those things but you end up having this
girl who's basically daria and doctor
strange right i don't know if you guys
ever watched daria great show back in
the day uh but she shows up here and
when when one of them kind of asks a
question like why are we all here she
chimes in and she says because of death
because of you because of us because of
life and it's just being really really
cryptic and really weird now part of
this is also because she's like that one
kid you guys know who i'm talking about
right like every every school has like
that one kid right like the one who's
off in the corner who believes they can
practice magic and it's just weird you
guys and here's the thing if you don't
know who that person was like to be the
bearer of bad news that person was
probably you but again you know the
question is kind of asked by emily like
what does any of that mean right like
what is your name and this girl says
like it's despair but you can call me
desi and so she says like i'm a demon
from limbo and i can see the dark
painful desperate side of things at all
times and yes i am a bit as he said
extra right like she's being kind of
extra here now here's something that i
want to clarify i really want to clarify
this because the nature of limbo can be
really confusing to people so there's
two different limbos in marvel comics
there is the realm of limbo which is a
true limbo right like it's where where
basically kane the conqueror was before
he was kang when he was immortus where
he like resided for a little while
that's the actual true limbo then there
is the demonic realm of limbo the demon
realm of limbo is the one you think of
when you think of like iliana rasputin
right aka magic the sister of colossus
that's who you're thinking of right like
that demonic realm where like madeleine
pryor made a deal with demons and then
the whole original inferno event from
the 80s kicked off that's who you're
thinking of right so the realm of limbo
is at least the realm that that desi is
from is from the actual demonic realm
she can also see what's truly in
people's hearts who they really are
beyond the surface and so that's why
when she's basically in a room with her
with her roommate like she asks her uh
you know what's what's it like you know
like what's it what's it like being here
you know where are you from and this
girl says like well i'm i'm from here
right i'm from new orleans this is home
to me desi responds and saying i'm not
talking about new orleans i mean your
secret right i know it's hard to keep
and this girl's like i don't know what
you're talking about she's like no it's
okay like i won't tell anybody right
i'll never tell it's my burden right to
know what's going on with people to know
their dark secrets but to never tell
anybody so like right off the bat it's
kind of like okay so like this girl is
apparently shady but that's kind of the
funny thing is literally like once they
get out there you know and they really
start actually taking classes right they
start their actual day that doctor
voodoo right jericho drums kind of like
okay you this is the first year of the
strange academy where he says like this
school has never existed nor has it ever
needed to exist but following the
restoration of magic to our world we
felt it was time to teach the sorcerers
of tomorrow now the reason why this
matters and the reason why this is
important is because what you had really
in in not too long ago a few years ago
is you had basically a story where magic
was destroyed by a group of beings
called the empirical now this ultimately
led to doctor strange going on a kind of
adventure in order to rectify that and
then to restore magic which i'm pretty
sure was jason aaron's run uh and
basically one magic was essentially
returned back out there to the world one
of the big things that steven strange
came to the realization of is that in
order for the empirical to basically
destroy magic they had to kill people
who could wield magic and in effect
doctor strange came to the realization
that in a lot of ways he had existed in
isolation that he hadn't really been
training people on how to use their
magic effectively especially young
people and so if something like the
empirical were to happen again these
young people would be defenseless they
wouldn't know how to cope with it not
only that because they are young and
because they are magical in a lot of
ways they're a danger to themselves and
others because they don't know how to
control their abilities and so one of
them is kind of like wait wait a minute
wait a minute so are we like superheroes
are we like superheroes
which admittedly would kind of be my
first question i'd be like are dude are
we superheroes now do we get costumes
i i would be excited man like i would be
over the moon if this was the case uh
but ultimately you know jericho drums
like no no no you're something else
altogether right he says like the
lessons are going to be hard like make
no mistake these lessons and what you're
going to be enduring are going to be
difficult they're going to be tough
these classes are going to challenge you
in incredible ways but we also have a
staff that is more than capable of being
able to teach you how to function
accordingly of course zelma is basically
the person that is the keeper of arcane
magical items the ancient one is back
and if you guys are interested in part
two we'll explain how the how the
ancient one managed to return or if
anybody out there cares you know if the
analytics show people care about this
video then
sure uh but then you also have damon
hellstrom who's one of the rulers of
hell you got niko minoru you got the
scarlet witch who needs no explanation
you've got magic and you've got shaman
so basically you have what is in effect
the creme de la creme of the magical
community all these beings here are
ridiculously powerful but then doyle
door mom who asked the one question
everybody wants an answer to okay i mean
this is cool and it's really nice that
we have all these people training us
what about doctor strange
where's dr strange this is literally
called the strange academy it was
created by doctor strange where is
doctor strange and the response to
jericho drama is like okay that's a good
question doyle like as you can imagine
he keeps exceedingly busy facing off
against various threats and and fighting
various people and then at that point
like a portal opens and just like a
thrall like this this just demonic being
just comes out and doctor strange is
like yeah come get some i'm ready just
like fighting this thing right just like
like just just facing off against this
thing and he's like you know i could
really use a lot of help here so
literally day one is all these kids from
the strange academy helping dr strange
fight this demonic being now this is
really
really cool and it's a huge motivator
right because if doctor strange just
didn't show up on day one i mean it
would be a little demoralizing but not
only do they actually get to see doctor
strange and the name of the school lives
up to what they expected they get to
help him fight on the first day son dude
that's that's legit right it's like
being able to play dodge ball in gym on
the first day of school it's just like
the coolest thing right it's like yeah
okay there's hope for this right like
this year is not going to be so bad
after all like literally the entire
happiness of the school year hinges on
the fact that you got to play dodgeball
on day one do you guys know what i'm
talking about right you guys know what
i'm talking about right it's just it's
one of those things it's just the thing
that improves everything and so of
course with the help of all these kids
who are and this is one thing to
understand they are guided along the way
right because they're untrained they
don't know how to work together they
don't know each other's strengths and
weaknesses so they're guided by like
zelma and they're guided by doctor
strange and the other members of the
staff because obviously strange in them
would never let anything happen if the
situation began to basically spiral out
of control and this being proved itself
to be more powerful than doctor strange
and a danger to the students here the
staff would have told the students to
leave they would have just like
teleported him away and the staff would
have fought along doctor strange to
defeat this thing right so that's what
would have happened if anything it's
just a teachable moment it's a training
session to give these kids an idea of
what kind of magic they will learn to
harness but also the kinds of dangers
that are out there and so ultimately of
course this thing is basically destroyed
and it's really really cool because like
doctor strange chimes in and it's like
okay so where were we right and jericho
drums like well i mean we're just kind
of giving them final words of
encouragement right inspiration you know
so ultimately doctor strange's like okay
don't die kids no he doesn't right but
he says like he's like i'm always here
to encourage and inspire those are
practically my middle names so here goes
nothing right he says i know some of you
are freaking out at how awesome and
scary all of this is and some of you are
probably thinking you don't need to be
here because you're such bad asses
already he says either way soak all of
it in have fun and most of all try not
to die right so he really does kind of
say try not to die but the reality here
is these kids are gonna have the time of
their life because strange academy is
just great with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end uh let
me know down in the comment section
whether or not you guys dig this because
it is really really fun uh thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace